welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and shongshi in the legend of the
tin ring's biggest enduring mystery was
its beastly antagonist the dweller in
darkness aka mega soul sucker it's not
just the suckin that's mega it's the
soul that it sucks champ mysterious not
only for being a giant tentacled kaiju
demon from another dimension introduced
late in the movie given no name other
than what its victims call it but really
for the way it telepathically
manipulates powerful people by
disguising itself as the voice of loved
ones making many wonder wait a minute
didn't wanda maximoff in the one
division post credits scene hear a very
similar disembodied voice
tell us the truth wand and you heard a
giant soul sucking dragon didn't you
well i actually do think both
wandavision and chongqi are setting up
the same marvel title doctor strange and
the multiverse madness but now i believe
this connection could be the missing
link so did wanda actually hear that
squid demon who just wants to give the
world a big kiss maybe but i actually
think what she heard goes beyond what we
saw in chiang chi by the way you gotta
check out our new shongxi inspired great
protector shirt at new
rockstarsmerch.com
this is the eighth latest obsession
design of collectible shirts and it's
the best way you can support what we do
here at new rockstars this shirt is
inspired by classic chinese art and the
climactic battle from the shengshi film
but this is a limited edition shirt so
you gotta grab yours now before they're
gone at newrockstarsmerch.com okay let's
break down everything chong chi told us
about this otherworldly threat when wu
tells sheng chi and xiao ling that he
plans to find the talo village to free
his wife lee from a cave in the
mountains saying i was sitting right
here in this seat deep in my research
and she spoke to me it's like she was
standing in this room i could feel her
breath on my cheek and her hand on my
back she told me she needed my help and
then later when sheng chi and jai lang
arrived to tallow nan explains that her
people have guarded the dark gate for 4
000 years that the realm of talo used to
have quote cities that surpassed any in
your universe until the attack of the
dweller in darkness he came with his
army devouring every soul in their path
and with each kill they grew stronger
after decimating our largest cities they
were headed to your universe to do the
same the leaders of tallow sent their
strongest warriors here to stop them
from reaching the portal to your world
but our ancestors were no match for them
until the great protector joined the
fight and turned the tide together they
pushed the dweller and his army into the
dark gate and locked him behind it and
then shortly after nan says your father
isn't the first to come here and open
the dark gate many have tried and failed
over the centuries and they all had one
thing in common they were lured here by
the voice of something on the other side
a voice that promised them their
greatest desires and then while sitting
in a study when wu suddenly looks over
and sees a vision of his late wife lee
who says we will be reunited soon and
then when wu makes it to the dark gate
the voice tells him save me to which one
movie responds i'm coming my love and
then begins punching the gate releasing
soul sucker drones his son returns to
fight him she takes possession of the
rings and then the gate shakes and the
voice begs release me release me more
desperate this time and then the giant
mega soul sucker bursts out but we never
again hear the voice of lee presumably
because at that point the beast has
already revealed its true form but i do
find it interesting that throughout this
battle it never even tries to use its
telepathy to communicate with or to
deceive or taunt or confuse its
prospective prey what a valuable asset
to have as a predator you could tell
these people anything to confuse the
hell out of them as you try to suck
their souls out this creature
essentially went from a super
sophisticated higher intelligence behind
the gate to just a typical thrashing
idiotic hungry hungry hippo kaiju
monster once it got out i am just saying
it is possible that the voice win woo
heard was not that mega soul sucker
creature itself but that the true
dweller or dwellers in darkness might be
some entity who wrangles this beast who
unleashed this beast the way the
monstrous eliath and loki was revealed
to be the attack dog of a string puller
the kang variant he who remains before
we continue this video is sponsored by
expressvpn the fifth season of rick and
morty just wrapped up and if you're
looking to binge all of the episodes you
could do that for free if you live in
the uk if you don't live in the uk
expressvpn can help expressvpn is a
virtual private network that encrypts
your data to keep it from being stolen
or tracked and can grant you access to
blocked content you can open yourself to
whole new libraries of content without
having to pay for a new streaming
service expressvpn allows you to reroute
your connection to a server in a country
of your choice making geo-restrictions a
thing of the past reroute your
connection to the uk and watch rick and
morty for free or european friends can
do the reverse and enjoy all of our
us-only content expressvpn is also
helpful for preventing your online data
from being stolen or monitored without
your knowledge i like how easy
expressvpn is to use no confusion no
wasted time and the whole thing runs
fast just fire up the app and connect
with just one click it's a top rated vpn
provider rated number one by techradar
cnet and many more find out how you can
get three months of expressvpn for free
by visiting expressvpn.com
newrockstars or clicking the link in the
description below now on the wand
division side of all this wanda does
hear the voices of her sons in almost
the exact same way billy and tommy's
voices call out to her in distress
begging save us with the same
poltergeisty audio distortion to suggest
they're coming from another dimension
[Applause]
[Music]
like when woo wanda hears them suddenly
in this room as if they're right beside
her and she hears them as she's in the
middle of research when wu was flipping
the journals in which he compiled
ancient documents about tallow wanda was
flipping through the dark hole the
ancient spell book of marvel lore now
earlier i underlined nan using the term
your universe repeatedly to remind us
that she was talking about this entity
coming from a separate universe within
the marvel multiverse and as wanda's
astro form reads through the darkhold
beneath that book wanda's red chaos
magic forms a flat disc similar to the
golden discs of eldritch magic formed by
the mystic sorcerers of dr strange's
network and floating around wanda are
three spinning globes which i think
represent distinct worlds or universes
that wanda is searching for her children
in the globe spin around her head as
lower on her body rings of red magic
float around her and notice on those
ring paths there is a fourth red globe
hovering just to the right of the open
dark hole her left hand seems to be
conjuring that one while her right hand
held higher up seems to be spinning the
other three over her head now why is
this imagery important and why am i only
bringing it up now well i pointed out in
my spider-man no way home trailer
breakdown that doctor strange's spell
uses eldritch magic with four rings that
orbit him spinning chaotically
physically colliding to represent
separate universes crossing over into
each other in that movie and in this one
division scene that fourth orb floats
leftward into the dark hold and that is
the moment wanda hears what she thinks
is her sons
now after chongqi i think that voice was
the dweller in darkness but not his
savage lapdog but whatever voice dwells
in the darkness beyond and i think this
contextualizes that beacon hidden in the
rings in the post-credits scene wong
formed eldritch magic projections of the
rings and he collided those projections
into each other layering them and then
discovered the beacon a beacon that he
said only activated when shengshi used
the rings to slay the mega soul sucker
an inter-dimensional beast that did not
belong in this universe that beacon is
alerting whoever dwells in darkness
still that to paraphrase thor and
avengers this realm is ready for a
higher form of war a war that we will
see in doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness which benedict cumberbatch
recently teased will rival spider-man
far from home as the most ambitious
superhero film of all time now it is too
soon to say what that dweller is
marvel's what if is hinting at some
recurring tentacled beast from another
dimension which does seem to correspond
with the speculation that the elder god
schumachorath could appear in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness of
course i've speculated other demonic
figures like catholic nightmare mephisto
but whoever it ends up being what is
more alarming now that we've discovered
is that the latest soul they have sucked
is that of the scarlet witch and as far
as souls go that's a pretty mega one
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow and subscribe to new
rockstars for analysis of everything you
love thank you for watching bye
[Music]
you